okay today I'm going to talk to you
about momentum now it's a bit of an
abstract concept every moving object has
a quantity of motion and that quantity
of motion is called momentum it's
essentially how much oomph an object has
if an object has more momentum it's more
difficult to get it to stop so momentum
relies on two things and I think it's
kind of easier when we start to see
examples
it relies on mass and it also relies on
velocity so the speed at which something
is traveling so again I think it's
easiest if we just have a look at an
example so let's imagine I have a man
right here this man he has a mass of 75
kilograms now he might be running at a
speed what kind of jogging at a speed of
5 meters per second so to calculate his
momentum it's nice and easy all I need
to do is his mass so 75 multiplied by
his velocity which is 5 so even if you
think you could do this in your head I
mean we always double check using the
calculator so 75 times 5 is 375 now the
units for momentum a lot of people get
wrong because we just multiplying them
together
it's just kilogram meters per second
there's no stroke sign here no do people
like to do per here there's no per here
because we just multiply them together
now let's imagine that instead of having
a 70 kilogram man but I apologize in
advance my terrible drawings of a van
all right there it is so let's say this
van is also traveling just 5 meters per
second okay but this time this van is
1,000 let's say it's 1,500 kilograms
okay so even though they're traveling at
the same velocity this one is going to
have a bigger momentum because instead
this is 1500 times 5 so therefore so
look at this 1500 times 5 the momentum
of this is going to be much bigger
7,500 kilogram meters per second rather
than this one so we can see it depends
upon the mass why does someone have a
look at another couple of quick examples
so let's say I've got another person
here but this person isn't moving at
this point they're completely stationary
so let's say they have the exact same
mass of this other person here they are
also 75 kilograms okay so this person
right now their momentum is 75 because
that's their mass multiplied by their
velocity because they're not moving
their velocity is zero so we can see
that stationary objects have no momentum
momentum is all about the quantity of
motion of a moving body right now let's
imagine this person here is also running
but this is one of the fastest people on
the planet they can run at 10 meters per
second okay so even though they're the
same mass the momentum is going to be
different because momentum relies on
mass and velocity so the bigger the mass
the hilum romancer the bigger the
velocity the heighten the momentum so
this time this one is 750 kilogram
meters per second so you can see even
though they're the same mass this person
has a greater momentum because they have
a greater velocity okay so that's the
basics of momentum let's have a look at
something a little more complex let's
imagine again apologies for my aweful
vans I'm not an artist let's imagine we
have these two vans let's say this van
is 2,800 kilograms and let's say this
van here is 2600 kilograms now what has
happened is this van has lost control
and it's going to slam into the back of
the other van at a speed of 10 meters
per second so what's going to happen is
it's not going to just stop dead both of
the bands are going to move keep moving
they're going to lock in and move
together like this so what I'm trying to
find is what is going to be the velocity
once the van bumps into the other van so
this works on the idea that momenta
is conserved the amount of the momentum
that the van's will have together
afterwards will be the same as the
amount of momentum that this fan had
initially so the first thing that I need
to do is find the amount of momentum
that this van had before the collision
so define momentum I do mass times
velocity so I'm going to do 28,000 sorry
2800 rather multiplied by 10 which is
going to give my momentum of 28,000
kilogram meters per second okay so
that's my amount of momentum before the
impact before the collision so what I
need to do now is find the velocity how
fast was the velocity going to be of
these two vans now they've collided so I
need to find the new mass which is going
to be the sum of these two because now
they're kind of locked together we need
to add these together to define my new
mass it's going to be two thousand eight
hundred plus two thousand six hundred
which equals five thousand four hundred
kilograms okay
so that is the combined mass of these
two now they've collided okay so because
of conservation of momentum momentum is
going to be the same after the
collisions before the collision to find
the velocity I'm gonna do momentum
divided by mass so my momentum is going
to be exactly the same as this van had
initially so to find my velocity I'm
going to do momentum divided by mass so
velocity equals momentum divided by mass
and it's gonna be the combined mass of
these two now they lock together so my
velocity is going to equal 28,000
divided by 5,400 now I definitely
definitely need my calculator for this
one so to quickly do this well the
velocity is going to be
t 8,000 divided by five thousand four
hundred and to do it to two decimal
places it's five point one nine meters
per second now that's what we'd expect
it expect it to be slower because it
started off at ten meters per second as
they collide they're going to carry on
moving but that is going to be the
velocity of their new movement and that
guys is basically momentum thank you